And what we're going to do,
actually, is do clustering twice.
The first thing we do is,
we're going to cluster in that big
feature space I was just showing you.
And those clusters are going to
be referred to as textons.
Now this is a word, I think it's a word
that was coined by Bela Julesz who was
a psychophysicist, guy who did random
autostereograms quite a while ago.
And they were referring to
things like T-junctions and
little end-stops and
other textural descriptors that ex,
existed in,
in images as sort of he saw them.
And the idea is that these clusters
in the feature space would
be different little textural elements
that were found in these images, right?
And so you would describe
each little window, okay,
by what's referred to as
its texton histogram.
That's what this thing is
going to be showing here.
We'll, we'll take a little
bit more of that.
But the idea is that, here there is
just a single value at every pixel,
which is the single texton that's
tends to be present at that pixel.
That is, which cluster it got mapped to.
And you can see that, you know, if you
were to just cluster based upon this,
it would be kind of weird because, yeah,
this is not one nice thing
because it's a single texture.
But the idea here is that,
even though this is a single texture,
there are all these different
little textons that are present.
So instead of segmenting the image based
upon which single cluster you're mapped
to, instead what we're going to do is
we're going to take little windows.
So here's a little circular window and
we compute its texton histogram.
Okay, so now we've got a whole
bunch of different textons and
this is the count of
the number of those textons.
So I get a histogram at every window.
So here's another window, and
it has kind of a similar histogram.
And here's a third window.
Well, its histogram
looks nothing like that.
And the idea is that you're now
going to cluster in the histogram
space of these textons in order to
be able to get your segmentation.
All right, and how well does that work?
Well, let me show you an example.
So here is a picture of a rhinoceros,
no, a zebra, I guess.
I don't know,
a thing with stripes, okay.
So suppose I cluster
it based upon color.
What would that look like?
Well, it would be a mess.
Okay?
And there's your mess, color-based
regions, and you'd say, well,
that's a terrible idea.
>> That's a terrible idea
>> So what would be a better idea?
Well, how about we cluster
based upon texture?
And you can see that you get these
broad clusters that seem to do,
you know, a reasonable job.
I mean, it, it does make the entire,
you know, this region here,
which is sort of this big region there.
You'll notice that it's not, you know,
because of the scales that got used in
this case, it didn't find these legs
here, or, or this one there, but
that's a function of sort of
how you go about describing it.
And I will say that in general,
this is kind of an under-segmented
result that probably should be more
segments, but clearly this is way better
than this color-based approach, because
it allows us to describe the texture.